Sudán está inmerso en la que podría ser
su tercera guerra civil desde la independencia.
En un país tradicionalmente dominado por
los militares, a mediados de abril estallaron
los combates para hacerse con el control de
Jartum, la capital sudanesa.
Se enfrentaban las tropas leales al general
que presidía el país frente a la milicia
liderada por el que hasta entonces era su
vicepresidente.
4 meses después la lucha continúa.
Jartum está siendo devastada y la violencia
se ha extendido a otras zonas de Sudán, adquiriendo
unos tintes de conflicto étnico que tiene
muy mala pinta.
El país se está hundiendo en el caos.
De momento no hay cifras fiables, pero todo
indica que el número de víctimas mortales
en estos 4 meses asciende a unas 5.000, provocando
más de 2 millones de desplazados.
Y muchos pensaréis:va, en el fondo, a mí,
qué me importa Sudán, que no sé ni siquiera
donde está.
Pues bien, Sudán importa mucho más de lo
que crees.
Con un tamaño similar al de México, Sudán
es el tercer país más grande de África,
y era el más grande de todos antes de la
independencia de Sudán del Sur.
Ocupa un lugar estratégico ya que su costa
tiene salida al Mar Rojo, por donde pasan
rutas que suponen alrededor del 10% de todo
el comercio marítimo mundial.
Además, tiene importantes recursos naturales:
tiene petróleo, no para nadar en zumo de
dinosaurio, pero ahí está su pequeña producción
de crudo.
Y sobre todo tiene oro.
Tanto oro como para llamar la atención de
Rusia o, por lo menos, del grupo Wagner, que
tiene vínculos con una de las facciones que
está peleando en Sudán mientras saca tajada
de sus explotaciones de oro.
Por si todo esto os pareciera poco, en Sudán
también tenemos un choque entre dos países
tradicionalmente aliados.
Hablamos de Arabia Saudí y Emiratos Árabes
Unidos, que están apoyando a bandos diferentes.
Además, lo de Sudán debería importarte
porque podría convertirse en una guerra absolutamente
salvaje.
Ya sabéis que los conflictos en África tienden
a recrudecerse una barbaridad y convertirse
en un baño de sangre.
El secretario general de la ONU, António
Guterres, ya ha hecho saltar las alarmas.
crímenes contra la humanidad.)
Ya lo veis, aunque sea por puro interés humanitario,
hay que enterarse bien de lo que está pasando
en Sudán.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Por qué ha estallado
un conflicto tan brutal en Sudán?
¿Qué intereses tienen las potencias situadas
detrás de uno y otro bando?
¿Qué puede pasar en los próximos meses?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a estas
preguntas, pero antes… vamos a ver un poco
de historia.
T1(LOS DIABLOS A CABALLO)
A principios del siglo XIX los gobernantes
del Egipto otomano conquistaron lo que hoy
se corresponde con la mayor parte del territorio
de Sudán.
No fue hasta 1899 cuando Sudán se convirtió
en un dominio del Imperio Británico.
Esta colonia consiguió su independencia en
1956.
Y mucho diréis: ¡qué buena noticia!
¡Qué bien que los sudaneses pueden decidir
su futuro convirtiéndose en una democracia!
Pues va a ser que no.
(Sudán es el país de África que ha sufrido
más golpes de Estado.
Desde su independencia se contabilizan 16,
de los cuales 6 han tenido éxito.
Los militares han acabado así con hasta 3
intentos de establecer una democracia en el
país, el más reciente en 2021.
Asimismo, Sudán ha vivido dos guerras civiles,
una de 17 años y otra de 22.
El conflicto desencadenado en abril amenaza
con ser la tercera guerra civil sudanesa.)
Habéis escuchado bien: de los 67 años que
tiene la República de Sudán, se han tirado
combatiendo durante 39, más de la mitad.
Fue la lucha de Sudán del Sur para crear
un estado independiente con una población
mayoritariamente cristiana, mientras que en
el resto de Sudan en esencialmente musulmán.
Finalmente, los sursudaneses consiguieron
su independencia en 2011.
Se llevaron el 25% del territorio y el 75%
de sus reservas petroleras.
[Eso sí, acuerdo mediante para compartir
esa riqueza.]
Ahora bien, estos recursos han servido de
muy poco al país más joven del mundo porque,
menuda sorpresa, en estos 12 años de independencia
ya han tenido su propia guerra civil de 7
años.
Pero esperad un momento amigos, porque las
dos guerras civiles son solo una parte de
la tragedia sudanesa.
Luego está el conflicto de Darfour.
Así lo denominaba en 2006 el entonces secretario
general de la ONU, Kofi Annan.
(Annan denomina a Darfur como "la peor crisis
humanitaria del mundo" RFERL)
En 1989 llegó al poder en Sudán el general
Omar al-Bashir.
Dominó el país durante 30 años y estableció
una dictadura dominada desde Jartum por una
élite islamista.
Sin embargo, en las regiones periféricas
del país las cosas eran diferentes.
En la región de Darfur convivían etnias
negras africanas dedicadas fundamentalmente
a la agricultura, como los fur, los zaghawa
o los masalit, con población de origen árabe,
dedicada al pastoreo.
Ganaderos y labradores se peleaban habitualmente
por el territorio.
En 2003 las etnias africanas, hartas del olvido
al que estaban sometidas por el poder central
de Jartum, estallaron en una rebelión.
Bashir mandó al Ejército.
Luego recurrió a los Janjaweed.
(Janjaweed significa demonios a caballo y
es el nombre de la milicia que utilizó el
Gobierno de Sudán como fuerza de contrainsurgencia
contra las etnias africanas.
Ante los escasos avances del Ejército, Bashir
armó a pastores árabes de ganado nómada
y los soltó sobre los granjeros africanos
negros.
La limpieza étnica fue brutal, con 300.000
muertos y hasta 2,7 millones de personas expulsadas
de sus hogares.).
La dictadura militar de Sudán ya acumulaba
por entonces un historial que habla por sí
solo.
Había sido uno de los cuatro países del
mundo que apoyaron a Saddam Hussein cuando
Irak invadió Kuwait.
También había acogido durante unos años
previos al 11-S a Osama Bin Laden, que organizó
en Sudán campos de entrenamiento de al-Qaeda.
Así que cuando el Gobierno de Sudán encargó
a los Janjaweed el trabajo sucio en Darfur,
Bashir se convirtió en el blanco de todas
las críticas hasta el punto de llegar a esta
situación en 2010.
(La Corte Penal Internacional emite orden
de arresto por genocidio contra Bashir.
Reuters)
Bashir se convirtió en el primer jefe de
Estado en ejercicio con una orden de arresto
por la Corte Penal Internacional.
No sirvió de mucho porque Bashir continuó
gobernando Sudán como si nada.
Y ahora yo os pregunto: si vosotros fuerais
el máximo mandamás de Sudán, ¿cuál creéis
que sería la única forma de perder el poder
al margen de que te dé un pampurrio?
Exacto, un golpe de Estado.
Así que para protegerse de su propio Ejército,
Bashir regularizó oficialmente a los Janjawed
convirtiéndolos en las Rapid Support Forces,
las Fuerzas de Apoyo Rápido, su particular
guardia pretoriana.
Al frente colocó a su mano derecha en Darfur:
Mohamed Hamdan Dagalo, un señor de la guerra
que se hace llamar Hemedti.
Bashir no supo ver su ambición.
(A nadie le gusta comer migajas de un banquete;
a todo el mundo le gusta sentarse a la mesa.
Dicho sudanés.)
Aislada internacionalmente, la economía sudanesa
se deterioraba cada vez más y la escasez
era cada vez mayor.
Las protestas populares se sucedían y en
abril de 2019 lograron su objetivo.
Sin embargo, amigos, para derrocar a Bashir
fue necesario…
Sí, lo habéis adivinado, un golpe de Estado.
El Ejército le dio el último empujón a
Bashir cuando vio que su dictadura estaba
tocada de muerte y Hemedti apoyó el golpe.
Bashir era prescindible.
Pero perder su posición privilegiada en Sudán
era algo que ni el Ejército ni Hemedti estaban
dispuestos a permitir.
Y como decimos en VisualPolitik, dicho y hecho.
(Máximo general de Sudán toma juramento
como líder del nuevo órgano de gobierno.
New York Times)
El general Burhan se convirtió en el jefe
de Estado de Sudán al presidir el nuevo Consejo
Soberano.
A su lado como vicepresidente situó a Hemedti.
Porque claro, no puedes dejar por ahí suelto
al tipo que lidera los Janjaweed, una fuerza
armada de 100.000 soldados.
Ahora bien, todo esto no le hizo ni pizca
de gracia a los sudaneses.
La gente no se había levantado contra Bashir
para que todo siguiera igual.
Así que los militares hicieron un pacto con
los líderes civiles: compartirían el poder
hasta celebrar elecciones en 2022.
Con estos ingredientes y el historial de Sudán,
¿Qué podía salir mal en la transición
a la democracia?
Pues sí, efectivamente: todo.
Atentos.
T2(EL ESTADO PROFUNDO VERSUS EL PRIGOZHIN
AFRICANO)
El acuerdo de 2019 para compartir el poder
entre civiles y militares era muy frágil.
¿Por qué?
Pues básicamente porque hay países que son
mucho más ricos; pero en pocos te puedes
enriquecer desde el poder al mismo nivel que
en Sudán.
Al antiguo dictador Bashir le encontraron
130 millones de dólares en efectivo en su
casa.
Sí, sí, en efectivo.
Controlaba la economía sudanesa a través
del Ejército.
Y, por supuesto, el resto de generales tampoco
tienen sus bolsillos vacíos.
Por eso, cuando el nuevo Gobierno civil aspiró
a fijar un nivel de transparencia y rendición
de cuentas digno de la futura democracia que
pretendían instaurar en Sudán, el general
Burhan sabía perfectamente lo que tenía
que hacer.
Y no, no estuvo solo.
(Sudán: Hemedti emerge de las sombras para
apoyar el golpe de Estado de Burhan)
Los donantes occidentales y los bancos multilaterales
habían prometido miles de millones de dólares
para apoyar la transición democrática.
Pero este golpe de Estado del general Burhan
y Hemedti, en octubre de 2021, impidió que
gran parte de esa ayuda llegara a Sudán.
Estados Unidos, el Banco Mundial y el FMI
detuvieron el flujo de al menos 1.400 millones
de dólares en ayuda y alivio de la deuda
sudanesa.
Entonces la junta militar tuvo que recortar
los subsidios al trigo y al combustible.
La situación en Sudán se volvió insostenible
y los militares se vieron forzados a negociar
con los civiles de nuevo para avanzar en la
transición democrática.
El pasado diciembre llegaron a un acuerdo.
News)
(Sudán establecerá un nuevo gobierno de
transición liderado por civiles el 11 de
abril)
El problema de estos acuerdos con los militares
es que tienen mucho que esconder.
El general Burhan quiere proteger lo que los
demócratas sudaneses llaman el “Estado
profundo”.
Hablamos de toda una red de corporaciones:
desde bancos y empresas de telecomunicaciones
propiedad de islamistas y oficiales de inteligencia,
hasta empresas propiedad del propio Ejército
que dominan sectores económicos como la fabricación
de armas, la construcción, la agricultura
y el transporte.
Algo similar podríamos decir de Hemedti,
convertido en los últimos años en el Prigozhin
africano.
(Hemedti es mucho más que un simple señor
de la guerra.
El dictador Bashir dejó que los Janjaweed
se hicieran con el control de las minas ilícitas
de oro del país, especialmente en la región
de Darfur, lo que convirtió a Hemedti en
uno de los hombres más ricos del país.
Asimismo, ha ganado aún más dinero y aliados
utilizando sus Fuerzas de Apoyo Rápido como
mercenarios al servicio de Emiratos Árabes
Unidos para luchar en Yemen contra los rebeldes
hutíes y en Libia al lado del general Khalifa
Haftar.)
El nuevo acuerdo de transición colocó contra
las cuerdas a los dos hombres más poderosos
de Sudán.
Los términos eran claros: Sudán tendría
un único Ejército bajo el mando del Gobierno
civil y las Fuerzas de Apoyo Rápido tendrían
que integrarse en el mismo.
Esto amenazaba claramente la posición privilegiada
de ambos.
La del general Burhan, puesto que el acuerdo
fijaba elecciones democráticas para 2024.
Y también la de Hemedti, puesto que en 2
años debía integrar su milicia en el Ejército,
algo que el Prigozhin africano pretendía
retrasar una década.
Por tanto, la única salida para ambos fue
el combate armado para ver quién de los dos
prevalece para decidir el futuro de Sudán.
Y ahí la capital del país se está llevando
la peor parte.
(Las calles de Jartum están devastadas por
conflicto militar.
Sky)
El problema de este conflicto es que es una
lucha equilibrada.
Será difícil que alguien se imponga.
El Ejército de Sudán no vale para mucho,
pero cuenta con aviación.
Las Fuerzas de Apoyo Rápido están mejor
armadas y tienen mayor destreza en combate
gracias a su experiencia como mercenarios.
Sus soldados no han tenido ningún escrúpulo
en tomar viviendas, escuelas e incluso hospitales
para hacerse fuertes en Jartum y llevar la
lucha, calle a calle.
Ahora bien, el Ejército ha bombardeado intensamente
la capital.
Y por si esto fuera poco, la lucha se ha extendido
por el resto de Sudán, resucitando viejos
fantasmas del pasado que amenazan con desembocar
en otro conflicto étnico.
Mirad.
(Darfur: los trabajadores humanitarios son
testigos de cientos de cadáveres asesinados,
incluidos niños abandonados en las calles.
Reliefweb)
Los Janjaweed cabalgan de nuevo y el riesgo
de nuevos genocidios cobra fuerza a medida
que el conflicto se prolonga.
Hemedti se erige como la fuerza rebelde que
se ha levantado contra el Gobierno legítimo
de Sudán.
Pero esto último es también cuestionable
dado el historial golpista del general Burhan,
que no es precisamente el mejor amigo de los
demócratas sudaneses.
El apoyo de las potencias extranjeras podría
ser el que decante la balanza hacia un lado
u otro.
Y hay muchos intereses en juego.
¿De qué intereses hablamos?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T3(EL TESORO DEL MAR ROJO)
Las principales potencias en el Mar Rojo son
Arabia Saudí y Egipto.
Por ello les interesa que se mantenga el statu
quo en la zona.
También en Sudán.
Sobre todo después de la caída de la dictadura
de Bashir, que se había acercado mucho a
sus rivales Turquía y Qatar.
Arabia Saudí y Egipto se sentían cómodos
con la junta militar de Burhan y Hemedti.
Su principal objetivo en Sudán era evitar
una revolución democrática en el mundo árabe.
Por eso apoyaron el Sudán post-Bashir.
Arabia Saudí se comprometió a invertir 3.000
millones de dólares.
Pero esperad un momento, porque Emiratos Árabes
Unidos dobló la apuesta.
¿Por qué tanto interés?
El mar Rojo tiene la respuesta:
(Emiratos Árabes Unidos construirá un puerto
en Sudán como parte de un paquete de inversión
de 6.000 millones de dólares)
A pesar de ser tradicionalmente aliados, como
podéis imaginar este puerto emiratí no interesa
ni a Arabia Saudí ni a Egipto.
Además, el favorito de Riad es el general
Burhan, que también es el preferido para
el general Al-Sisi por los estrechos lazos
que mantienen los Ejércitos de Sudán y Egipto.
Sin embargo, amigos, ya os he contado que
el hombre de Emiratos Árabes Unidos en Sudán
es Hemedti.
Así que todos estos intereses cruzados enlazan
con la estrategia creciente de Abu Dhabi de
desplegar todo su potencial económico para
rivalizar con Arabia Saudí como el referente
del mundo árabe.
(Mientras el príncipe Bin Salman caía en
desgracia en Occidente tras el asesinato de
Khashoggi, Emiratos Árabes Unidos ha tratado
de mostrarse como el rostro amable de la región.
Al final han mostrado intereses diferentes
en Yemen y en Washington, donde Abu Dhabi
ha tratado de reemplazar a Riad como el aliado
militar favorito de Estados Unidos en el Golfo.)
Bin Salman no ha rehuido la rivalidad y ahora
trata de recuperar terreno.
Podemos verlo a nivel deportivo.
Que los Emiratos compran el Manchester City,
pues los saudíes compran el Newcastle.
Que hay Fórmula 1 en Abu Dabi, pues también
en Arabia Saudí.
Y todo así.
Por lo tanto, volviendo a la guerra de Sudán,
ahora mismo la prioridad de las potencias
regionales no es tanto la paz como que se
imponga el bando que apoyan.
Más aún si en la ecuación añadimos al
Grupo Wagner.
El oro que consigue Hemedti en Sudán está
llegando a Rusia de contrabando a través
de los Emiratos.
La Casa Blanca ha tardado un poco, pero por
fin movió ficha contra Abu Dabi.
Mirad:
(Dos empresas de armamento vinculadas al ejército
sudanés, han sido sancionadas por EEUU.
Mientras tanto, Al Junaid, un trader de oro
controlado por Hemeti y su hermano, y Tradive,
con sede en los Emiratos Árabes Unidos, también
han sido sancionados.
Middle East Eye)
Los vínculos del grupo Wagner con Hemedti
se remontan a 2017.
En principio, Wagner habría dado armas y
formación militar a las Fuerzas de Apoyo
Rápido a cambio de acceso al oro de Sudán.
Si este vídeo lo hubiéramos hecho hace meses,
ahora os hablaríamos de cómo Rusia extiende
su influencia por África.
Pero después del motín de Prigozhin el escenario
ha cambiado.
O quizás no tanto.
Si el Kremlin quiere mantener las alianzas
logradas por Wagner, tal y como se ha escenificado
en la cumbre con países africanos que se
acaba de celebrar en San Petersburgo, necesita
a Prigozhin.
Y su economía más.
(La economía de Rusia está siendo apuntalada
por las operaciones de contrabando de oro
de Wagner Group, según un informe del gobierno
del Reino Unido.
BusinessInsider)
El oro de Sudán es demasiado interesante
como para que el Kremlin y Wagner dejen caer
a Hemedti.
Burhan también tiene un buen apoyo con Arabia
Saudí, que en 2022 fue el quinto país del
mundo en gasto militar, tan solo por detrás
de Estados Unidos, China, Rusia e India.
Así que todo indica que la guerra de Sudán
se va a prolongar en el tiempo.
Estaremos atentos ya que estos conflictos
suelen desatar una violencia enorme.
Mientras tanto la pregunta ahora es para vosotros.
¿Cómo creéis que evolucionará la situación
en Sudán?
¿Se implicará directamente alguna de las
potencias extranjeras?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.